[Applause]  Rhianna mindy kaling and anne hathaway  the cast of oceans eight stole the show  at Monday night's Met Gala and radiated  in this red Valentino gown Rihanna who  co-chaired the event Slade and silver in  this sparkling Pope inspired look it's a  Margiela artisanal gown by John Galliano  and check out Mindy Kaling and Sarah  Paulson et was with Olivia Munn on the  carpet who also stars in the film she  looked fierce in this gold a gem gown  with a matching headpiece I feel there's  no way that dress is super comfortable  the original star of the oceans  franchise George Clooney looked dapper  with his wife Amal who also co-chaired  the event here's the catch the new  all-female reboot centers on the Met  Gala what do you think about the oceans  movie that you started the franchise  being around the Met Gala is funny I  think I gotta watch out they might rob  me tonight  [Music]  you